en este vídeo veremos un ejemplo para la
descomposición en fracciones parciales
de una expresión racional solamente
veremos un ejemplo porque algunas veces
puede ser un poco largo entonces
empecemos con 3x menos 8 entre x
cuadrada menos 4x menos 5 ahora lo
primero que siempre hago es tomar en
cuenta dos cosas
miren el grado de el numerador siempre
debe ser estrictamente de un grado menor
al del denominador que es lo que ocurre
aquí y también necesitamos preguntarnos
si el denominador se puede factorizar
bueno dependiendo de cómo se pueda
factorizar sabremos cómo hacer la
descomposición y en este caso si el
denominador se puede factorizar podemos
factorizar lo como x menos 5 x x 1 ahora
una vez que ya factor izamos observen
que nos quedan dos factores lineales
distintos así que vamos a intentar
separar esta función racional en dos
fracciones
diferentes en una de ellas el
denominador será x
5 y en la otra el denominador será x1 ok
ahora necesitamos conocer las constantes
a y b si encontramos los valores de a y
b suponiendo que tenemos un común
denominador que en este caso al
multiplicar arriba y abajo por x 1 y
multiplicando y dividiendo entre x menos
5 al final podremos regresar a la
función racional que teníamos
originalmente entonces existen varias
formas en las que podemos hacer esto
pero la forma en la que a mí me gusta
resolverlo es que sin importar lo que
tengamos en el denominador de la función
original simplemente voy a multiplicar
ambos lados de la ecuación por eso de
esa manera nos podemos deshacer de la
fracción y esa es la idea entonces si
multiplicamos ambos lados de la igualdad
por x
5 por x 1 del lado izquierdo
todo eso se cancela
sólo nos queda 3x menos 8 y del lado
derecho al hacer la multiplicación al
multiplicar por la primera fracción el
término x 5 se cancela y así nos queda a
por x más 1 + b que al multiplicar el
término x 1 se cancela y nos queda por x
menos 5 ok ahora hay un par de cosas que
podemos hacer una vez que llegamos a
este punto podríamos empezar a
multiplicar todo y después resolver el
sistema de ecuaciones pero miren cuando
cuando nuestros factores son lineales
podemos usar un pequeño atajo también
podríamos usar el método de igualar los
coeficientes pero eso no lo veremos en
este vídeo mejor usemos el atajo fíjense
al analizar el primer término podemos
ver que tenemos a x x 1 y al analizar
específicamente x + 1 qué valor
podríamos sustituir en x para que
podamos deshacernos de todo el término
bueno en este caso si sustituimos x
igual a menos uno nos quedaría a por
cero y así el término se va entonces
hagamos eso vamos a sustituir x igual a
menos 1 en toda la expresión
tenemos que 3 x menos 1 menos 8 es igual
a a x menos uno más uno más por menos
uno menos cinco entonces teniendo esta
ecuación sustituimos x igual a menos uno
y al hacer la aritmética del lado
izquierdo nos queda menos 3 menos 8 que
es igual a menos 11 y del lado derecho
nos queda a por 0 que ya dijimos que es
igual a 0 y después tenemos b x menos 6
así que al dividir ambos lados entre
menos seis nos queda menos 11 entre
menos 6 o simplemente podemos decir que
ve es igual a 11 entre 6 recuerde
nuestro objetivo es encontrar el valor
de las constantes
en la descomposición original entonces
esta es nuestra vez ahora hagamos
exactamente el mismo procedimiento pero
esta vez en lugar de deshacernos del
término que involucra a la constante a
vamos a deshacernos de be y para eso
simplemente necesitamos sustituir el
valor de x por 5 positivo si hacemos eso
del lado izquierdo nos queda 3 por 5
menos 8 y eso es igual a a por 5 más 1 +
b por 5 5 ok entonces del lado izquierdo
nos queda 15 menos 8 que es igual a 7 y
del lado derecho nos queda a por 6 que
lo podemos escribir como 6
y observen que el término de b se va
porque nos queda de x 0 y finalmente
podemos dividir ambos lados entre 6 y
así nos queda que a es igual a 7 entre 6
así que en conclusión podemos decir que
la descomposición en fracciones
parciales
separamos 3 x 8 / x
5 x x 1 es igual a a entre x 5 y
encontramos que el valor de a es7 sextos
más b que es igual a 11 sextos entre x +
1 esta es nuestra descomposición en
fracciones parciales y lo que podríamos
hacer después de esto es encontrar el
factor común para regresar nuevamente a
la fracción que teníamos originalmente
porque queremos pasar de una fracción
condensada si lo quieren ver así a
factores individuales como los que
tenemos del lado izquierdo entonces esta
es nuestra descomposición en fracciones
parciales